هذه قصة عن طعام الطائرة ، وأنا
أعلم ما تفكر فيه ، لكن هذا ليس
مجرد طعام للطائرة ، هذا هو كريم
دي لا كريم كريم المحصول الذي يتم
تغطيته بالجليد في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، وآلاف
الأعمال وأول-  يستمتع ركاب الدرجة الأولى
بوصفات الذواقة اللذيذة والرائعة من الشيف
مات وفريقه المؤتمن ، دعونا نرى كيف
تنطلق الوجبة ، نحن هنا في أحد
مطابخ بيضة لا تزال حيث يتم إعداد طعام شركات الطيران
، أنا الشيف مات وهؤلاء
من بين فرقنا لدينا غرفة تخزين
لإنتاج الطهي والنقل
عبر مطابخنا الثلاثة في أتلانتا ، نقدم
180 ألف وجبة في الأسبوع لوضع
نصب أعيننا أننا نستخدم 30 مليون شريحة
من الجبن سنويًا في الولايات المتحدة  إلى جانب
85 طنًا من السبانخ ، ستصل ثمانية ملايين
فراولة و 25 مليون شاحنة توصيل لفائف الخبز
وسيتم فحص درجة حرارة العناصر ، ثم
يتم نقل هذه العناصر إلى
المنطقة الخاصة
بها ، وسيتم تجهيزها وطهيها
ثم تعبئتها في شركة الطيران  رقائق معدنية وصعودها
إلى العربات التي يتم
دفعها بعد ذلك إلى شاحناتنا
وتسليمها إلى الطائرة ، تكون
الكابينة أقل رطوبة كما نفعل على
الأرض ، فأنت بحاجة إلى الرطوبة من أجل الحصول على
النكهة الكاملة للمذاق الكامل للطعام ، لذلك
صممنا حقًا  حارب ذلك في
الهواء حتى تجد الكثير من
العناصر المليئة بالتوابل العالية ، ونود
حقًا إبراز تلك العناصر بحيث
يتذوق الطعام على الأرض كما
هو الحال في الهواء ، مثل
سمك السلمون المدخن الساخن مع المانجو و  إدامامي
بوراتا حليب الجاموس مع بعض
شرائط الخيار وبعض اللآلئ
البلسمية ، سمك القاروص المشوي مع هريس اليقطين بالشمر مع أوسان
تشارلز بدون حلويات ، أتناولها فقط  ar أثناء
تصميم وجبات الطعام ، أبحث حقًا عن
عاملين رئيسيين وأن الطعام
يستخدم الكثير من الأحماض والأعشاب الطازجة
لتعزيز تجربة الركاب
على متن الطائرة
، وأعتقد أنني محظوظ جدًا لأن الطعام
الذي أصممه سواء كان شخص ما ذاهبًا في
إجازة أو يسافر  للأعمال التجارية
هي أول ذوق لديهم في
مغامرتهم الجديدة وأعتقد أنه سيكون من
حسن حظهم أن يكون هذا هو آخر طعم
لديهم قبل عودتهم إلى المنزل
[موسيقى]